we're learning more about a police
scandal in Northern California racist
and homophobic text messages sent and
received by dozens of officers five
people are now suing the city of Antioch
claiming a pattern of police abuse in
the Bay Area suburb lease Preston is an
Antioch just east of Oakland Police good
morning
good morning Nate 30 years ago Antioch
was a mostly white community and many of
the black residents here now say they
actually left Oakland to escape police
brutality not only do these hateful
messages show an extreme bias among some
of the officers they also show them
bragging about beating people while on
patrol and fabricating evidence
they basically ruined my life one by one
when it comes to these officers it's
always they word against ours Antioch
residents and plaintiffs who are now
suing the city and several police
officers shared their stories after a
report released by the FBI and local
officials found some 45 of its 99 police
officers sent and received racist
messages dating back to 2019. I'll bury
that n-word in my Fields said one text
another said bro they all look the same
to which an officer then responded I
feel like I'm at the zoo
there were multiple texts referring to
black people as gorillas and monkeys one
officer even appeared to admit since we
don't have video I sometimes just say
people gave me a full confession when
they didn't
these officers supposed to be protecting
and serving and they out here hurting
and killing people Jarrell goms's son is
one of the five plaintiffs in the
federal lawsuit she says the officers
texted about brutally beating him what
did they say
they said that my son's head is like a
a bowling ball and try to kick them
unconscious and they bragged about it
and laughed about it tension in the city
has been high Marilyn marthorpe became
emotional during a council meeting last
week after a resident who was defending
the officers accused him of misconduct I
am sick and tired of being attacked by
these people in this community why do
you think that these officers felt so
bold to be able to write these text
messages the culture the culture the
culture the culture because in no place
would this be acceptable unless the
culture said it was acceptable
now we reached out to the Antioch Police
Officers Association and have not heard
back the chief of the apartment he
issued a statement last week condemning
those racist texts and the behavior of
the officers Tony
shocking there Elise thank you very much